well that's such a large sum of money
100 billion is such a large sum of money
that you would be very wise to take on
board a team of highly professional and
intelligent people to advise you it
would be foolish just to give it away
without any thought you might say I want
to do that and then find someone saying
but frankly we already got the money for
that or what a waste of money because
they would blow it away they'd spend it
if you had that amount of money you'd
have to be very very cautious so the
first thing I would do is I would bring
in a team of people half of which would
have had a vast amount of money
themselves never give money to people
who've never touched it in their lives
before they'll spend it in a few moments
bring round you people who've had
millions there'll be a damn sight more
cautious so half my team would be
millionaires who'd built their own
fortunes the other half would be people
wise people who knew about real problems
and where the money could be wisely
spent